[Música]
buenas tardes
gracias a alguien los invito a quien
hace posible esto
yo soy frida guerrera se están poniendo
en las cruces y solamente en este país
y que compré me respetan que nos quiere
ayudar teme una cruz
para una de esas cruces es la historia
de una mujer
en una clase de sociedad en este país
no está buena demás
los comentó las cruces que están
pintadas un poquito más bajitas son
niñas y un bebé
pero las más grandes son adolescentes y
mujeres que es grande
2016 2017 y 2018 19 y 20 han sido
asesinadas no las transmitidas no me
caben ya en la camioneta
soy singleran
como te ayudo
hacer la extensión de tu voz
es lo primero que yo le digo a una
familia
a una prima a una hermana a una madre un
padre que lo buscan amigo de mis redes
sociales aportaciones de mi celular
conocerás sus pesas de algunos de ellos
que me abren este dolor que me abren las
puertas de su corazón
la primera reacción que tienen estas
madres sobre todo estos padres las hijas
los hijos de estas mujeres es horas
yo no digo nada no puedo decir nada
porque
lo primero que nos dicen a estas
familias es eso no llores supéralo punto
de pasar
eso nunca va a pasar
después de que llegamos a estos
domicilios
a la primera
al primero ente que yo tengo que
investigar a que tenga que entrevistar
es algo luz
las familias hablan
porque el deber se nos permite
y entonces les pregunto cuéntame qué
pasó
y empieza la relación del infierno
una entrevista de este tipo a mí me ha
llevado hasta 8 horas
porque más que una entrevista es eso
abrazándolos
[Música]
entender y decirles sobre todo
qué se debe
a las familias se los dio se han
enquistado en lugar de corazón
si creemos que una familia que ha sido
tocada por un tema de feminicidios
algún día me va a superar estamos
muy equivocados porque eso nunca se va a
superar ellas me pidieron se le
asesinadas ninguna de ellas
darle más a la ausencia es lo que yo
hago
cuando iniciamos esto lo iniciamos con
esa intención
tenemos más de 30 años gritando en
ciudad pero nuestros temas designando y
son mujeres y son jóvenes que están
también de los pueblos que están
saliendo a trabajar y lo escuchamos
ni las autoridades ni la sociedad ni las
personas se detuvieron a voltear a ver
ciudades tales y decir
pero eso es una frontera eso es porque
haya que ser que les pasa los que se
pasan los lindas para acá y entonces
matan a las mujeres
ser la extensión de la voz eso que a mí
me toca ser
yo decidí formal a ver y es una a la vez
clave porque quiero hacer porque es
porque solamente me convierto en la
extensión de esa voz soy la pluma
de historias de vida de mujeres y niñas
asesinadas y que las únicas personas
autorizadas
para contarles son sus familias después
de esa pregunta
después de llorar de abrazar las de
ponerle el 100% de mi atención
después de que me cuentan cómo
encontraron a sus hijas calcinadas de
estas aves en sus casas
de veras después de diez días después de
dos años después de un año si es que
tienen suerte
les digo ahora presenta me la
y entonces
las conozco
nunca debe conocer a ninguna de las
mujeres que ustedes tienen ahí
nunca me da a conocer a daniela que era
una niña de 4 años
que fue asesinada a golpes por su papá
hasta la fecha profundo hace ya más de
un año
y la que me la presentó fue su mamá
nunca voy a conocer la realidad una niña
de 11 años asesinada en monclova por un
menor de 13 años inimputable por cierto
que nunca pisó la cárcel
y sus otros años
yo salí
de pesar
de quién era mi pareja en ese entonces
con la nariz rota una costilla
una hemorragia vaginal que ni siquiera
me di cuenta que traía
y fue entonces que decidí dejarla
comodidad el confort del consultorio
dónde
abrazada con niñas con niños con mujeres
tenía grupos de mujeres a las que les
enseñaba
cómo ser feliz siendo mujer
pues entonces decidí
ver mi voz
a quien la ocupada
decidí simple y sencillamente ser el
instrumento para que aquellas personas
que no pueden perder un medio de
comunicación tuvieran uno en mí
soy fotógrafa hago vídeos escriba una
columna desde el 2007
y desde entonces no ha parado
en 2016
en febrero del 2016
después de un mes dice de infinidad de
amenazas de muerte que he tenido que
pasar tres no abandones del 2009
para vida a finales de ese año
un tercer levantón donde me torturaron
esto todo en oaxaca se vivió 11 años en
oaxaca
tuve trabajado en mi perfil
al hacer mi perfil tuve que trabajar
amparadas la brazada de las personas que
para mí sabe que son políticos eran y
son mis amigos
y entonces me va a ser un poquito del
perfil
y en ese 2016 busqué feminicidios
no encontré nada
empecé a poner mujer calcinada en mujer
que me da mujer descasada mujer asesina
de su casa en línea en contra de
asesinada y encontré 193 registros del
primero de enero del 2016 al 20 de
febrero
eso me horrorizó
lloré mucho porque no me parecía justo
que se quede de motas rojas si no había
organismos haciendo estas
documentaciones
pero cuando estoy recogido esos informes
no se quedaban más que en la fuente con
las mismas defensoras y no basaban
y además de todo para el rostro de la
sociedad tampoco se veía
empecé a fomentar esto
pero desde ese mismo año dije no no
podemos nada más contarlas hay mucha
gente que lo está haciendo ya existía
entonces el mapa de maría salieron
también qué
paralelamente estábamos como empezando a
hacerlo
y empecé a buscar familias
para qué
para darles voz y rostro
medite desde ese 20 de febrero
hasta él
desde el primer minuto de mi vida hasta
el último que me queda que a veces son
más de 25 horas al día
en dedicarme a buscar a documentar
a ir a buscar a las familias a hablar
con ellas a preguntarles quiénes eran
esas niñas y esas mujeres a las que les
asesinaron
él es demasiado
al principio no duermes porque también
estás un claro del infierno todos los
días
no es sencillo a ver cómo los aniquilan
a diario
en decirme
quién soy hacia dónde voy
pero sobre todo tengo decirme que a
quien yo me presento que son las voces
de la ausencia este grupo de madres
padres hijos hijas sobrinas hermanos
a los que lleva el disfraz y en 2016
justamente por tratarse de las meses de
sus hijas de sus mujeres asesinadas
quisiera se escuchen en esos años
difícilmente difícilmente
se escuchará a las familias
si escuchaba a la que llevara la
organización a la que llevara el grupo
[Música]
pero difícilmente hablaban ellas
estaban testimonios nosotros vamos a
muchas ponencias así como ahorita con
ustedes con una firme intención
sabes
que se puede hablar del tema del
feminicidio sin amarillismo
y sin revictimizar
claro que ahora les duele son sus hijas
clave plato 2 debería devolvernos la
mayoría de estas nuevas que están aquí
fueron asesinadas en contubernio con sus
madres
y para ellas nadie grita
y por ellas nadie habla
no hay quien cuente la historia
la intención de ir a dar estas ponencias
ayuda las facultades a los docentes a
donde nos inviten
es para justamente contar sus historias
crear conciencia y evitar
sobre todo que nos sigan arrancando de
nueve a diez mujeres todos los días
puestos de la ausencia no es una lucha
no es un movimiento
nosotros respetamos desde fría guerrera
y voces de la ausencia esos movimientos
pero esto es una causa
la justicia
la verdad y la reparación
la labor de frida de la balanza
escribir historias
contar historias narrar el infierno hay
un libro que se llama hasta ni una más
que es de mi autoría y ahí están algunas
de las pocas historias que hemos escrito
durante todos estos años
en abril de 2006 inició con estas
historias y yo no dejo de escribir una
historia cada semana
hemos compartido historias de mujeres
vivas escritas por ellas sobrevivientes
porque ya no queremos que suceda
que nos toca hacer como sociedad
para parar el dolor
después de que yo empecé
van a ver historias
vi que no había respuesta a las
autoridades 2017 marco para mí unos
meses antes
la respuesta de las autoridades
patitas ropas encontraba 18 de marzo
2017 alma verde social está el virgen
del camino en el estadio en méxico en
lechago al coyote
semidesnuda
su madera verde agua
al mes nadie le había reclamado
nadie había preguntado por una niña una
niña de tres a cinco años
al preguntar a las autoridades me
dijeron nada mejoraron
y entonces la adoptamos mi compañero de
vida y colaborador y yo conocí a una
hija asesinada
si ahorita estamos en muchos medios de
comunicación ahorita somos la bruja que
hay que quemar en la hoguera
pero en ese tiempo no había me plaga
a la sociedad le valió madre perdón
no nos estaba importando una niña con
las piernas abiertas después de haber
sido violada
y dejar en un terreno en el estadio de
méxico nadie se indigna
nadie pensó en sus 20 cuentas justicia
para la niña de las tarjetitas rojas
ocho meses nos tardamos con mis propios
recursos porque en efecto nadie nos paga
cómo podemos contábamos para la gasolina
nos decían es que creo que sacar es que
propicio y yo no tenía un rostro para
que alguien me ayudará a identificar a
esa niña
el septiembre de ese año alguien sea
clave de la loquita de saca sean sus
transmisiones en facebook live y en
facebook que la subida después de
youtube
y me mandaron tres imágenes del día que
encontrado en el cuerpo
[Música]
jamás nunca mostró el rostro de lupita
como lo dejaron nunca
solicito el acuerdo entonces en redes
sociales de una dibujante y se acerco a
una
hizo el primer rostro
a los días se acercó una técnico forense
y me dijo yo te hago el rostro
sin gol ante un peso a lápiz
era más o menos los primeros días de
noviembre
entonces los medios volvieron y dijeron
también que a poco todavía me
identifican a la niña
25 de noviembre de 2017 vía facebook
me contacta la tía de la niña
y me dice creo que es mi sobrina
las llaves
las basuras fotos reales a ellas a nadie
más
porque para retratar un infierno no
necesitas comer la imagen de una mujer
oa una niña como la dejaron asesinada
y el efecto era de ella esperamos
14 de diciembre me escribe una persona
en twitter y me manda una foto de la
niña
al siguiente día acusar a la única
familia que la quiso rescatar
y entonces la vid diciéndome me llamo
lope
el 17 de diciembre lo entregamos a la
fiscalía del estado de mexico para la
investigación la dirección de los
presuntos asesinos de la niña el nombre
de la niña como le decían porque no está
registrada
y a la familia
el 3 de diciembre del año pasado fueron
sentenciados yadira la mamá de la niña y
pablo su padrastro a 88 años de cárcel
cada uno
la niña por primera vez en este país fue
registrada ya muerta el host otorgó y
dio la orden se giró la orden al
registro civil para que la niña fuera
registrada porque merecía un hombre que
no ha descalzo tita rojas su nombre
guadalupe medina pichardo
edad cuatro años
asesinada a golpes por su padrastro y su
madre
dejar en un terreno envuelta en una
cobijita
y un tercer regreso cuando era niño yo
estaba asesinada
la desde ya y viva la niña muerta
ese es méxico y hace la diferencia en la
que hemos vivido como sociedad
necesitamos abrazarnos necesitamos
cuidar a nuestros nuestros bebés
no podemos ya dejar de escuchar lo que
está pasando no podemos ya no meternos
no podemos ya decir pues es mi hija si
quiere me la trago pues no te la traga
es porque también es mi responsabilidad
ahora se monos
no es un tema yo jamás voy a decir que
esto sea una guerra de hombres contra
mujeres
es una guerra contra la impunidad contra
años de mensajes de la puedes asesinar
de esta estar comete la enterrarla
volver delante a desenterrar llevarla a
tirar a un terreno ir por ella
enterrarla en tu casa y difícilmente te
van a investigar y difícilmente te va a
pasar algo
entonces en este caso empezó a
investigar el ayudado a la detención de
40 presuntos homicidas
muchos de ellos tres sentenciados
porque no podemos quedarnos en la ciber
indicación porque no podemos quedarnos
sentados esperando a que las autoridades
hagan su trabajo
solamente siendo fría guerrera de estas
voces de la ausencia de estar
constantemente hablando de todo esto
darnos cuenta que todos todos tenemos
hemos vivido algún tipo de violencia
cuál es el objetivo de nosotros
y seguir creando conciencia seguir
contando estas historias para evitar que
nos estén arrancando en este momento a
otra mujer a otra niña
y seguir hasta que estás ni una más
justas
ni una menos deje de ser una realidad y
no gastas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]